le traumatisme des New Yorkais s'estompe
malgré tout petit à petit mais le
souvenir du 11 septembre reste encore
très présent pour ceux du moins qui
habitent où vont à l'école près des deux
tours qui ont disparu c'est le cas de
ces étudiants d'une école qui avait vu
sur le World Trade Center Isabelle
Bechler Tristan lebra reportage des
chicanes de béton pour pénétrer dans un
lycée commercial de 2700 élèves voilà
une conséquence du 11 septembre
l'établissement est voisins du QG de la
police new-yorkaise nous sommes en
pleine zone sensible à 300 mètres à vol
d'oiseau du site des tours jumelles
l'avant après du paysage a choqué tout
le monde même les professeurs ne
réalisent pas vraiment l'absence des
tours
d'ici la plupart de nos élèves ont pu
voir les avions dans les tours la fumée
et tout ça je ne veux pas oublier mais
en même temps parler trop souvent d'une
histoire aussi triste c'est déprimant
il y a plein de rumeurs de nouveaux
attentats dans le métro moi j'habite
loin et tout peut arriver sur mon trajet
de train je ne suis pas rassuré
et les corps décomposés on doit respirer
des tas de choses pas très nettes c'est
pas bon pour la santé
personne ne peut oublier que le site
brûle encore à proximité l'inconfort est
constant
on dirait une odeur de produits
chimiques brûlés théâtre c'est agressif
ça fait rougir les yeux ça donne la
migraine
certains ont des problèmes respiratoires
les adolescents ont passé 10 jours chez
eux avant que l'établissement ne rouvre
l'agence pour l'environnement avait fait
des mesures de qualité de l'air
apparemment satisfaisante du moins sans
trace d'amiante et les professeurs
avaient reçu quelques conseils pour
inciter les élèves à évacuer le
traumatisme